el jefe de Los mercenarios rusos Wagner
ya no se encuentra en Bielorrusia sino
que estaría aquí en la ciudad rusa de
San Petersburgo lo ha dicho esta mañana
el presidente bielorruso Alexander
lucasenco recordemos que lucasenco tuvo
un papel crucial a la hora de que prigó
sin y el crimen alcanzasen un pacto para
que el jefe Mercenario no fuese
castigado por su motín y se exiliase en
Bielorrusia lucasenco ha dado pocos
datos sobre el paradero de prigosin
parece que en efecto voló a San
Petersburgo aunque también se ha visto a
uno de sus aviones privados despegar
desde San Petersburgo a Moscú y de ahí
al sur de Rusia aunque no sabemos si
prigó sin también viajaba en ese aparato
lo que ha dicho lucasenco esta mañana es
que está dispuesto a colaborar con
Wagner y a ofrecerle algunas bases de la
época soviética para que Los mercenarios
de Wagner se puedan desplegar en
Bielorrusia Aunque dice que todavía hay
que a dar algunos flecos de esa
negociación porque parece que los banner
tienen en mente algún otro tipo de
despliegue Tal vez más ambicioso que
lucasenco no ha querido detallar sí que
ha dicho que no está preocupado por el
despliegue de mercenarios en su
territorio en territorio bielorruso un
hecho que sí que ha alertado a vecinos
de la otan